la corvée de bois voilà un beau chantier
au milieu de l'hiver
certes il y'a plus de saison mais la
question est ailleurs yat-il encore
assez de et dans les campagnes après 50
ans de restructuration agricole et
d'arasement rassurons nous il y à des
exceptions vieille exemples à l'appui
sylvain maillard exploite ses 10 km2 et
il utilise 50 mètres cubes de bois
déchiqueté pour se chauffer et ça ne lui
coûte que 2 à 300 euros pour l'année son
énergie il la puise chez lui moi j'ai
déchiqueté il ya deux ans dès que j'ai
planté par je suis installé il ya 25 ans
quoi c'était le fruit quoi pour moi de
pouvoir déchiqueté un mois que j'ai
planté
c'était quelque part ap 20h paysans
heureux devenu depuis peu président de
la société coopérative bois bocage
énergie
le collège des producteurs continuent de
grossir c'est normal puisque ce sont eux
qui sont les principaux approvisionneurs
en bois donc on a pour rappel le
renouvellement du contrat de la du parc
naturel régional du perche qui se
chauffent avec nous on est donc bien ici
au croisement de l'économie
collaborative et du développement local
prend le bois de notre exploitation se
chauffe avec ont fourni la commune à
côté
effectivement et puis on travaille avec
les cuma pour le jt est tout a donc il
ya les élus un gros pied les producteurs
et aussi des techniciens qui régissent
et avec le technicien
l'animateur de l'ensemble pas la peine
d'aller bien loin pour chercher de bons
exemples à chanu où se trouve le siège
de bois bocage énergie la mairie et la
plupart des bâtiments publics se chauffe
au bois
notre rôle c'est de fédérer les
collectivités sur la mise en place de
chaufferie bois et le rôle du technicien
est basse et d'accompagner la
collectivité pour voir si c'est opportun
ou pas mais ce que l'économie du projet
là et est-ce qu'il ya la place aussi
pour le faire et ensuite de
l'accompagner jusqu'à la réalisation des
travaux et la mise en place de la
chaufferie et on est ici dans le circuit
court en s'efforçant de récolter la
matière première dans un rayon de 10 à
15 km autour des clients quant aux prix
ils sont fixés en commun sans recherche
de bénéfices juste l'équilibré
c'est ça aussi la scic société
coopérative d'intérêt collectif et c'est
autour de tout ça tout le monde comme on
travaille travaille aussi à la
replantation il faut boucler la boucle
c'est le cercle vertueux encourager
l'entretien et la réparation leur
maillage du territoire pour la suite ici
ce qui est à envisager ma part
proposition d'agriculteurs c'est de
reconnecter un petit peu ces parcelles
et son bocage donc on a des plantations
prévue l'année prochaine ici pour
reconnecter là et qu'on va planter au
bord de la route et la laque et au fond
et certainement aussi une reconnexion la
haut cour un exemple parmi d'autres
c'est avec ces résidus extrait dans les
parages et non avec des bâches plastique
que l'on protègera les jeunes pousses le
développement durable est inscrit dans
la charte de la sic
le nouveau gros business du bois de
chauffage les chaudières géante
approvisionné on ne sait trop comment
très peu pour eux il y a une
un autocontrôle si on peut dire en
interne et puis quand on a des chantiers
qui dérape de façon ça se sait très vite
et dans ce cas là on intervient auprès
du producteur et si tout le monde joue
le jeu du raisonnable
on arrivera à voir une belle filière qui
va être renouvelable personnellement je
suis un passionné de l'oeil bocagères
mme gemme pas sur les circuits devait on
pourra plus y aurait plus bocage quoi et
je suis un amoureux de lège en amoureux
de la pause quoi proposer ce pourquoi on
bosse quand il ya une ressource locale
de développer il ya un emploi à la clé
quoi on oeuvre dans cette façon là que
de travailler là et de faire conserver 2
et de transmettre aussi de transmettre
cela renouveau journée de passage quand
on transmet